Setsuko Thurlow welcome to Scandinavia
you live in Canada but but you were born
in Hiroshima and you've spent your life
working against nuclear weapons and you
were actually there when it happened
please tell me where exactly were you
well I was a 13 year old grade age
student and in those days we students
were mobilized to help the army and
municipal governments and so on and on
that very day I was up the army
headquarters about 30 of us had been
recruited to be trained as decoding
assistant we just got to the army
headquarter which was 1.8 kilometer from
hypocenter about 1 mile I was on the
second floor of the wooden building I
saw the bluish white flash in the window
and then my body was thrown up in the
air I do remember the sensation of
floating in the air because all the
buildings were flattened by the blast
and obviously the building I was in was
falling and my body was together falling
so you can know you can only from from
the detonation itself what you remember
is the flash and yourself in the air
that's right not no sound well people in
the distance heard that roaring sound
but I didn't I was right in it and
sometime later I found myself in the
total darkness and silence and I knew
what was happening to me I was faced
with death I tried to move my body but I
could
then I started hearing whispering voices
of the girls around me mother helped me
god help me I remember those voices
belonging to certain people they're
still ringing in my ears from time to
time all of a sudden from behind that
somebody shook my left shoulder and with
the male voice said don't give up keep
keep moving keep kicking keep pushing
I'm trying to free you and he helped me
and he also suggested that I should
crawl to the direction where the sound
Ray was coming through so I crawled out
in the total darkness I began to see
some moving object approaching me for a
while I couldn't say what those black
things want but then I could tell they
were injured human beings they didn't
look like human beings I'll tell you
their hair was standing up like while
the wire standing up and they were
covered with blood and skins were
scorched flattened and skin and flesh
were hanging from their bones and part
of the bodies are missing and some
people I know it this is gross but
carrying their eyeballs in the eye in
the hands and they were slowly shuffling
from the center part of the city but did
they collapse onto the ground when they
collapse their stomach burst open with
the intestines stretching out this kind
of situation I witness then the soldiers
said ugurus join that procession in
escape today
outside so so we did that by allotted
what did Hiroshima look like from from
there well I couldn't see the entire
city but what I could see was the area I
escaped to together with those ghostly
figures by carefully stepping over the
dead and dying people at the foot of the
hill there was a army training ground
about the size of two football fields
together and the place was packed really
packed with the dead bodies and dying
people seriously injured people this
strange thing was there was no screaming
and yelling nobody had that kind of
physical and psychological strength you
know look help me help me I'm in trouble
nobody all they could say was in whisper
water please
water please well we escaped in three
girls were not injured so badly so we
wanted to be of help
but we had no cups and bucket to carry
water so we went to the nearby stream
washed off or the blood and we thought
of our blouses and soak them in the
water and dash back to the dying people
and put it put the wet cloth over their
mouths and they just sucked in the
moisture that's the level of rescue or
relief work and I looked around and see
if I could see doctors or nurses none so
tens of thousands of people without
medication without any care and not even
drops water only few fortunate ones were
able to get water from
how have you coped with this mentally
through the years you've talked a lot
about it you like you talked about it
it's not how you cope with it I think
that that's wrong yes healthy way of
dealing with yes and you also spent a
lot of your life working against nuclear
weapons
do you do you think that the people who
have not experienced what you have
experienced are able to grasp the
consequences of nuclear weapon of a
nuclear detonation certainly good if
they put their mind to the issue if they
are interested in finding out what kind
of world we are living in then you can
read you can think you can talk yes you
can use your imagination it's possible
they can't say only the survivor can
understand the horror and the survivors
in spite of the pain we are the
recalling our experiences and speaking
out around the world because it's not
the thing of the past 70 years ago but
it has been going on the past you know
almost 70 years the situation hasn't
improved at all it got worse and worse
at that time only two bombs which were
used on earth mentality we thought it
was a catastrophic situation but now we
have sixteen to seventeen thousand
nuclear weapons so the world has become
a worse place to live but most of the
people have their heads in the fund
today you're 82 years old and almost 83
hey eighty three and a half no more than
that and and you you've been you you
wanted to tell your story and many
survivors from Hiroshima did not want to
tell necessary they kept quiet why is
that that's not accurate
yeah many people who what's too painful
to look back and believe them experience
but a lot of people have come to come
out of that Nam Nam condition they are
willing they are actively engaged in
sharing the experiences one final
question
I wonder you've had a long life now yeah
and your life starting with this
gruesome experience which it is has that
changed do you think your perspective on
life
certainly that contributed to the change
yes of course I was raised in the family
where service to the society was very
important but having experienced that
and having lived in the aftermath of
that where poverty hunger discrimination
or all the ill you can think of but some
people were so courageous they devoted
their lives like my church minister
devoted their lives to support help
those people and a young teenager I
wanted to be like those people who are
helping people so I chose my field of
Social Work that became your line of
work so she's like a social worker peace
activist
I have led a very busy life yes thank
you very much thank you please welcome
John please